foreign
folks here we are we might be drunk
we're back dumb babies oh let's say it
again we got samj here
well you hate it what my pet peeve is
like dumb dumb kids yeah yeah so just
kids no I think there's kids who like
you look at them and even if they're
doing kid [__] kids are going to do kid
[__] yeah but they got like life in
their eyes and you can tell the wheels
are turning and they're thinking in
there and then as he's dead in the eyes
just like dummies yeah and I hate when
people bring me those type of kids and
want me to engage with them because I'm
like I don't there's nothing I could do
with this like the kid is dead enough
there's nothing going on you're carrying
that entire interaction yeah and I
already don't really want to interact
with a kid no like at least let them be
will you never have kids either thing I
don't think so no um but you're in a
you're in a serious thing and you happen
for a while yeah but but kids it's it's
come up or no I mean yeah but we're like
lesbians so you have to produce ways
around it I know but that's what I'm
saying you have to make so many
decisions and I just don't think we're
gonna make them that's a good point you
can't it's not like an oops
it's mad decisions and choices and I
just don't think we're ever gonna get
there if you did adopt would you go
different race
I used to do this joke about how I was
going to adopt the Chinese baby
um because that's how lesbians show that
they got money and people people got mad
at me really it's funny people get mad
over everything yeah
do audiences get mad no like I think
people like when I say people get mad
it's like it's always usually after the
joke is out somewhere and then they're
like how dare somebody say that on a
Saturday night and make people have a
good time jokes like all right bro
you're watching this Tuesday yeah like
you're coming in the wrong time yeah
it's literally like someone opening the
door during sex and being like well I
wouldn't [__] you and like I'm not
asking you to exactly what's the problem
yeah
but no yeah I wouldn't I would adopt
another race I always think maybe later
in my life I might like adopt like a
teenager or something but then just
because you know I was like a teen with
no parents and [__] like that but and
then I think like I don't know teenagers
just a lot and I don't wanna have to
stab a [__] 14 year old because they
acting crazy in my house yeah do you
want to establish the dominance at a
younger age because they act up it's
like you really gotta stab them or
something exactly yeah teen comes in hot
that's right you're missing this part of
their life and you're going right to
this that's that's tough yeah but the
teens no one wants them once a adopted
kid gets too old it's like that's why I
thought about doing it because right
once you get like left the most and you
only have to put a few years in you know
up you're 18 now I did my two years yeah
good luck out in the real world fatty
yeah why they fat wow he calls everyone
fat oh okay that's like his old buddy
old pal that's it yeah all right plus
the fat ones don't get adopted either so
you want to help them out too is is it
like the pound do you walk in and kind
of point
I remember I was talking to a girl once
who adopted a dog and she goes I said
did you adopt one she goes none had that
it Factor ah wow that's a pretty
horrible thing to say I don't think
you're going in with the right attitude
well I knew a girl she would adopt a dog
and hang out with her for a week and go
it doesn't feel right she would bring it
back I was like you killed this dog
that's messed up it's like have you
adopted you got to stick with it but
that's a that was a big covert thing
yeah I feel like a lot of people were
like I wanna I wanna pet and then they
got back to their regular life and were
like never mind yeah that's pretty
[__] up oh yeah Kevin ISO did that
really yeah he was bringing the dogs to
shows and stuff for a little while and
then I just I was like what happened to
the dog he was like I gave it back dog I
was like bro what
now here's the question do that with a
kid I think you can actually really but
yeah I'm pretty sure that you can damn
that'll [__] a kid's head up yeah would
you break up do you say it's not you
it's me
I don't think can you bring it I don't
think you can bring a kid back I think
you I think you can if you can give up
every orphanage that's what I'm saying
if you give up your royal kid for
adoption I'm pretty sure you can give an
adopted kid back right it should be a
trial how are your biological kid I
should say you take a car for a test
drive can I get two days with a kid ah
now you're gonna see if we Vibe that's a
good question I don't know
I like that you're thinking about having
a kid yeah give it a couple years you're
married now right oh yeah that's crazy
crazy I never thought anyone would want
you like that Mark yeah that's why I did
it she was the first person to say I
would I was like are you married it'll
never happen again
in the lesbian relationship who proposes
to who I mean I think it's different for
every every
couple but I
have unfortunately so the [__] falls on
me but I can't speak for everybody it's
different for every situation you know
you do the 1D the Kaepernick I did the
one there I did the whole thing nice
yeah I know what type of lady I'm
marrying
she wants the whole show I did it too it
feels weird I was nervous it's scary
even though I knew she'd probably say
yes I was still freaking out I was
pretty confident but still he's maybe
not exactly what do you do at dinner or
what are you doing I um I did it at my
birthday party which it was like my
birthday was kind of like to hide the
fact that it was really an engagement ah
wow that's nice how long you been
together uh I've been dating my fiance
off and on for 15 years
that we're not doing it a lot but when
when we do it bomb as [__] all right
that's what I'll say like we don't [__]
a lot but it's really nice when we do
[__] because it's like oh yeah your
[__] is fire as [__] it's like you
forget and then you're like oh [__] no
this [__] is fire you know what I mean
yeah it's kind of it weirdly brings you
back to each other yes oh hell yeah
right this is this is why I'm in this
into this as much as I'm Into You like
as a person you got fire [__] and I
forgot about it was that the proposal
don't you know those wallets that light
on fire get a ring that just blows up
yeah fire [__] yeah
a fire [__] love a fire [__] but yeah
it's it's great when you when you uh
have that SEC that old sex again and it
comes back and you're like oh yeah this
is what we were doing 15 years ago and I
think now we're like we're at a place I
think before it was like you gotta grow
up you know so at some point it was just
like this contentious place where she's
like why aren't you [__] me and I'm
like stop making this my job you know
what I mean like it just becomes like
it's weird back and forth but now we're
both at this place where we're like we
just want to be [__] more so we're
both just like doing things and making
the effort to make sure that happens
right and that's been working out like
pretty far like we went to the Poconos
oh like six months ago to like [__] like
like poor people yeah and that [__] was
fire there's somebody I got a hotel with
a circle bed and the nasty and it had
the uh the champagne glass jacuzzi oh
wow yeah and everything was leather like
all the couches everything was leather
oh good because we had a pool inside the
room damn it's like cool yeah like a
little door you opened it had like a
little heart shape oh yeah you don't
talk about it oh sure and then we just
we just we just we just [__] like nasty
people well it's something about a hotel
because at your house you get sick of
[__] there it's the same routine over
and over in a hotelier it's standing up
your scissors take the [__] to other
spots exactly like that gets you really
like when I take my girl like out the
country then I'm like I want to see what
this [__] do in Paris
you gotta travel the [__] around
it's nice to just throw a condom wrap on
the floor and be like someone else will
deal with it I don't use condoms my
dick's plastic yeah
no it's nice to make a mess of a room oh
dude I'm [__] on drapes yeah that's
crazy yeah that's fire yeah I wish I
could just you can't squirt I can't
squirt bro oh give me an hour
I would have to like reassess my entire
existence
your psychology when Mark does he goes
comedy oh boy
I did it yeah squirting I feel like
nobody mentioned squirting until
1999 and now it's all it's like eating
ass it just came in one day yeah and
it's like a big debate is like now like
I see on the internet it lives like men
be like mad like all of it ain't squirts
this argument is it P or is it squirt
yeah and I think I think the amount of
women who are saying they could squirt I
think some of them pissing I think so
because it feels like it's like a real
skill you got a home oh yeah because you
know what I'm saying because like as
women the pressure point feels to say
you know what I'm saying it feels when
you feel that even like if there's like
a big digging units like and you're like
oh a minute like you feel digging like I
gotta pee you don't that's what the
pressure kind of makes you feel a little
pp-ish interesting I guess just pressing
against your spleen give me the same
feeling when it's please baby I don't
know you've never done that and I
believe you it sounds like you got them
are you a gold star gay no oh okay so
you dabbled with the the mail all right
the mail yes you lost your virginity we
did that podcast together we talked
about you lost your virginity to uh I
was a basketball game yeah
point guard playoff game oh wow and I
was watching basketball wow
[Laughter]
I've seen you rolling with your Jalen
Brown jersey yeah yeah yeah I like Jalen
Brown a lot yeah damn
that's well when you were doing it where
you're like this isn't for me no
no I was young and I didn't
when it was happening I wasn't like oh
my God I feel so gross afterwards I was
just like yeah yeah this is fine and
then I had sex with I didn't understand
what people loved about sex I was just
like it's fine right I mean like that's
where I was with it like my homegirls
were like eating it feels so good when
you feel it in your stomach and in my
mind I'm like I don't like that part I
don't like feeling it in my stomach or
like ugh that's not cool to me but like
it's fine yeah but so I didn't have that
like association with it and then when I
had sex with a woman and I was like oh
yes oh yes no it's fire you know what I
mean yeah
I just you know it was a little bit
clueless sure well we had the same
sexual history I started with a guy
it is it is weird to start that way it
is weird to like for the first your
first
sexual experience is just not what you
like yeah yeah that's true but you don't
know what you like either so I didn't
know that I didn't like it as much as I
just was like I'm not feeling how
everybody else is feeling right you know
I mean but I didn't I I mean I came and
stuff oh wow but I was just like I don't
know it's fine yeah I don't need this to
happen but it's a different come when
you're with a woman oh for sure for sure
for sure for sure for sure but now you
say you're the guy and are you doing all
the the pegging or whatever you call it
the strap bombing I think it's called
pegging when it's a woman oh well what
do you call it we know what kind of porn
Market
you guys that'd be pegged all wrong
and so but you're behind and you're
doing the pumping they don't got to be
behind sometimes I look my girl in the
eyes baby what's up not me I'm a lover
oh yeah no I don't get strapped if
that's what you're asking you don't like
it um I mean I'm I'm good all right I'm
good I like the power Dynamic I got
going yeah I know no crazy [__] to my to
my household yeah
they should make strap-ons that shoot a
little load or something about those
they do hey baby it's like Spider-Man
you just shoot like this you like hit a
button and then they're like
really yeah bang it's a little flag some
of them is whipped cream
whoa some of them it's like a lack of
fluid it's all good that's a tough one
to break out of the dinner table yeah
it's a lot of Make-Believe going on yeah
I love that button it's just in his
butthole
milk the prostate oh yeah this is like
the like the they got vibrator straps
all types of [__] Whoa man yeah we have
a friend I don't know if I'm not gonna
say them we all know him but he's a big
Peg guy really loves getting pegged and
now I can't see them different I see
them differently wow yeah I'll tell you
after I wonder who it is oh very close
it's mad
interesting yeah I mean I don't I can't
say I would like maybe when I'm old and
[__] because like I feel like your
sexual appetite changes for sure and
whatever so I don't ever say no ever
never to anything because I ate [__]
you know what I mean so like I know I'm
open right right but as of right now I
couldn't really I couldn't see that no
pegging is like oysters you can't come
out of the gate with oysters you kind of
have to develop a pallet for it you know
yeah you don't see a 16 year old with
eating oysters yes yes yeah you give it
a shot but then they say a woman's
sexual prime is mid to late 30s
it's a weird design because we're 18 19
20. no I'm still horny I mean I am too
but
I don't know like it might have
something to do a biologically like uh
your clock oh right like your body
feeling like hey we need to reproduce
maybe yeah the shot clocks winding down
I know I definitely like feel that now
where it's like
my body is going because I've never had
kids and like my body is going into like
hyperdrive it's like is your body saying
I want kids it's like you need to do
this you need to get you need to get
interested like my periods are a lot
worse than they've ever been in my life
because I feel like I'm producing women
with estrogen and [__] during that time
because my body is like girl
we need to we need to make something
happen even women's bodies are passive
aggressive that's crazy they make
something happen yeah like my periods
are crazy now like when I was young
girls would complain like oh they say I
didn't feel [__] I'll have like a
three-day period I'd be like this really
ain't that big of a deal yeah and now
it's like I feel like nauseous my
titties swell up my nipples be sore like
wow it's like misery it's like misery
and I know it's my body being like [__]
being a woman's heart oh yeah biology is
the ultimate misogynist makeup baby now
you know yeah right yeah damn yeah my
lady's got the IUD so no period shooting
all over the place all good I'm happy
for you shooting up the club that's what
we call it it's Orlando in there
yeah but then she has to do the waddle
to the toilet which is always awkward
well if I shoot it let's get in graphic
but if I shoot it in her She's Gotta
it's gonna fall out it definitely falls
out it does the IOD falls out no no the
jizz oh yeah yeah it slides on down oh
yeah yeah so pretty ID comes out and I
was like that would be no no no no never
seen that [__] but you can feel that
thing sometimes on your head paper clip
yes oh yeah yeah little pee hole action
yes that stinks and it's kind of sharp
it's sharp yeah it's awkward yeah not a
fan I'm sorry Mark
but you know we were just oh you said
this shooting thing and I was just
watching uh Saved by the Bell like just
was on TV today that screen the old one
but Screech would have been a school
shooter today uh the [__] he went
through he was just in love with the
girl it never works out Lisa Lisa yeah
that's the one I saw like Zach is
kissing Lisa yeah always gets a little
feelings hurt I know but that's always
that's also like a good lesson to these
new kids that act like nothing feelings
like that [__] Screech was a dog
because he used to just get his feelings
hurt everybody was always kissing on
this [__] and he still hung out with
them [__] yeah he still was like yo
like this ain't personal right you know
what I mean I just happened to be a nerd
Dad
this is just the world yeah he also was
like this is as good as it's gonna get
all right the streets was cool and then
he also like he just allowed himself to
grow in that and then he became the
principal remember like he took over
back oh yeah right that's what nerds do
they tend to win in the end yeah they
struggle in high school I don't remember
I didn't didn't stick with it that long
oh the College Years the College Years
he was a principal oh yeah yeah he was
like a well hi up there yeah worked at
the school and [__] exactly that's how
it goes you bully these kids all day
then before you know it they're the CEO
I do watch college Years too oh yeah
it felt like they you could whip that
script it was great oh yeah but you have
to think it was writing for our young
brains yeah so it was good like I feel
like kids need more [__] I'm like I
don't know I see what they watch on
Disney Channel now and I'm like oh yeah
worship was like our [__] was like it
had depth yeah it was a little more
adult hell yeah remember Jesse was on
the drugs yeah she was trying to study
I'm so excited she was all spun out
the no dose the words yeah it's [__]
up there's no time this excited was like
Jesse
was a heaven that [__] no no yeah see
that is this drug addiction it was like
racial tension with Lisa sometimes it
was heavy stuff hell yeah Family Matters
too
yeah I used to love that I used to I
mean [__] I was just watching the old
clips because I was thinking Larry
Johnson remember he was cross-dressing
that was ahead of his time grandma on
family man
oh yeah yeah and get us insight into the
future of the WNBA
one guy became a porn star one of the
one of the girls on the show scrape a
porn star yeah that's right Dustin
Diamond we came before I started I'd say
it was a star
Screech is packing heat that's the whole
for him he already needed something that
was the whole the whole deal is his dick
big whoa and he stabbed a guy Justin
Diamond stab somebody oh yeah pull it up
Screech so maybe he kind of did turn
into it
whoa
whoa he's got a cut dude yeah that's
six-pack Screech his abs is that him his
face looks a little different
well all right close up more close-ups
here I think that Screech bro damn
I really became a school shooter yeah
got good meat that's whatever yeah good
he needed something good for him that
must have been a tough you just you're
watching that show and you're like if
any one of these characters dies first I
got my money on screen it also doesn't
mean it's up to be Screech and got like
this huge dick and then every day for
your like role they just emasculate you
you're just like a giant dog in your
pants I'm sure he got laid though like
in the early 90s I'm sure he was you
know he's on TV there were some novelty
[__] coming out oh yeah but he was
getting butt for sure but Zach Morris
was definitely getting better [__] oh
so he was like my dick bigger than his
though and how about slater I mean he
was [__] up Slater's the man still
looks good Jason Slater looks better now
you have any later stories never never
sat in a chair frontwards just a goddamn
the coolest guy on the planet tank tops
the school guns out yeah plaid shirts
yeah yeah a shag yeah and a little curly
mullets rough come on man that's a bad
one as people of color we call it a shag
we don't we don't have curly mullets we
don't have mullets it's a shack he's a
white guy though no he's no he's
hispanic Lopez look at that look at this
dimples come on what a hunk come on
little cut off of football oh yeah
showing a little stomach uh-huh get the
[__] out of the Shag he's still ripped
he's on E2 I would have [__] Slater
for sure
would he still [__] later is there any
dude that you get a whole pass for oh
like who I like love yeah yeah what if
Jalen Brown was like I want to [__] you
um
I don't like those like like when I
think about [__] guys it's like it's
not usually the usually the guys like I
like admire it's usually like I have a
very particular type it's not that type
I like I
dreamy white guys like you gotta be
classic California
yes like GB yes okay it could be like
that give me that
or
you gotta be like
hmm
like I like Paul Rudd oh yeah he's cute
does the fact that he's kept it together
do something for you because he's in his
50s but he looks great he looks amazing
because I'm attracted to older women
before I saw at the Knicks game and I
had to let him know I was like you fine
for real what'd he say like I was like
sir I am very gay but you know you are
very [__] fine that's the ultimate
combo he's fine as [__] really I don't
normally like your gender but for you
I'd make an acceptance oh my God he is
pretty fine it's like oh it's like
classically just he's just very good
he's a handsome guy he just oozes yes
like [__] me yeah what'd he say when he
said that he just laughed and smiled and
I got wet oh so he's still got some some
stuff in there for the guys
I mean I think there's a level of
hotness it's just like who doesn't yeah
I hear you you know what I mean it's
like you fine man yeah I'm not in the
dudes but I can if I see a good looking
guy I'm like whoa that's a handsome yeah
and then you have to think I took dick
so my [__] remembers
[__] flashbacks yeah the [__] never
forgets it's like an elephant
damn yeah you ever hooked up with a guy
I made out with a boy when I was a kid
it's in my special at Bay you know the
bed no that's right I was in second
grade oh oh yeah it's pretty innocent
yeah it was like a full makeup though
like yeah we made it out you couldn't
remember this tongue yeah yeah
Who is the boy gay now I don't think so
I think it's just weird I think he just
kind of grew up to be kind of like a
curious kid like I'm curious because I'm
weird you know I mean sure I think how
did you leave feeling do you remember
the feeling or you're just like I
remember telling my mom I think I'm gay
and my mom was like you're not
she didn't even let you leave but she
was just like I know you're not I can
tell I'm your mom I'm gonna allow you to
be interesting she's like she would have
been she would have been fine if I was
but she's just like I know no no that's
what I'm saying it wasn't like oh you
can't be gay it was well like you don't
got it like you don't got it
she said the same thing when he wanted
to be a comedian
she's like you don't have it I know you
think you're interesting but no baby
no but I definitely uh I would have
taken it further with this kid he was
kind of The Brood I was like I remember
I said to him I was like what are what
are the gay people do and this is how
much we knew about homosexuality he said
they rub dicks and I couldn't get a hard
dick at that point in my life so I was
like I said let's do it and he goes no
I got shut down I would have taken it to
that place
yeah I got rejected second grade is not
really boner time no but I think I just
was like well this is in my head that's
what we're really liking this dude I
liked it
he had big I feel like he really liked
the skin he had big pouty lips he was
kind of feminine I think that's why I
deterred him from being gay this
rejection you might be gay deep down
inside yes but this early rejection
[__] you up I looked back at it and he
had pouty lips he was kind of chubby so
he had tits and I was thinking my head I
was like this is the closest I get to a
girl right now he's hairless he was
hairless yeah you're not scared just a
pedophile
hey folks we might be drunk as brought
to you by fume cold turkey is delicious
but cold turkey is a terrible way to
break your bad habits fume is the fun
all natural way that can help you kick
that habit fume uses all natural
delicious flavored air for you to
breathe so you can replace that hand to
mouth feel no electronics no Vapor no
harmful chemicals that makes sense
because it's really all about that oral
fix say you know he's got to go back and
forth back and forth something to do
often we walk into a social situation I
tend to grab a beer or grab my tits but
yeah you gotta uh you gotta do something
and fume is a way to do it without
killing yourself those Vapes I don't
trust them I'm not I'm a vape apologist
so I think it looks good it feels good I
took a few whiffs myself and I God it
tastes great
and the new version is fun to play with
fun to hold and you pull it out it's a
conversation starter it's a good time
your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
give your fingers a lot to do and help
you de-stress while breaking your habit
put a [__] on there let me play with
that
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching a fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fuma
served over 100 000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume to
help break up your destructive Habits by
picking up the journey pack today head
to trifum.com and use code drunk to save
10 off when you get the journey pack
today that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code drug to
save an additional 10 off your order
today get some few
it's display time baby this plate is the
cool new metal poster you'll want in
every room get your own artwork printed
on a one-of-a-kind metal poster that
takes only 20 seconds to install they
have officially licensed designs from
Fight Club alien South Park and more
your poster comes with a magnetic
sticker so just pop it on the wall and
and hang your poster no power tools no
wall damage easily switch out a new
poster in seconds click the link in our
description to see some of our favorites
and get ready to hang a piece of art
save 22 if you buy one or two and get 33
off when you buy three or more the
discount will be automatically applied
to your cart when you click the link use
code drunk when you visit display.com to
get the discount that's display.com code
drunk or click the link in the show note
you might be drunk as brought to you by
Babble baby if you're taking a summer
trip abroad in 2023 you might want to be
able to walk but walk and Tuck the tuck
that's why you shouldn't go anywhere
without preparing with Babel Babble is
the language learning app with
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons so there's still time
to learn a new language before you reach
your destination
three
I travel a lot
I was just down in Mexico and it
embarrassed me embarrassing I took it in
high school there's the subway sorry
it's in real New York experience I'm
Underground
comedically and literally but uh yes get
on Babel learn a language expand your
mind queef it up
with lessons that take a little under 10
minutes a day you start having a real
life conversation it's almost three
weeks hey
choose from 14 different languages
including French Italian Portuguese and
more Babel 11 their voiced by real
native speakers not computers and can
access podcast games video stories and
even live classes to help you on your
way plus comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee
pretty good
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
drunk that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com for up to 55 off your
subscription Babble language for life
you were just in the movie uh you people
you had a big role I haven't seen it yet
honestly but I heard I heard it well
then we're not going to talk about it oh
why I don't know I saw it you agree
thank you yeah no I heard you were
hilarious that's fine it was fun A lot
of good jokes in the movie yeah it was
fun
yeah I mean Eddie Murphy and Julie Lee
Dreyfus two Titans of Comedy what was
that process like did you audition for
it or were they just like we want you
the second that's pretty damn that's a
nice place to be Jonah write it for you
who's the other writer Kenya wrote it
together no they originally I wrote the
world for a guy
and then um Kenya just called me and was
kind of like yo
I got this part and I think you could be
dope and um that was it damn real fit in
there yeah some real facts about
racial relations on our country I wasn't
ready for okay that's cool that's dope
the Muslim Jew stuff you mean that stuff
yeah yeah
it's fun let's dive in you know we're
getting away from that in comedy let's
go back to that where we just talk [__]
yeah go go towards the the [__] I mean
that's what like honestly I I
that's what kind of attracted me to it
at all was like
they are trying to have an honest
conversation yes in this as much as you
can in a Hollywood vehicle with all the
Hollywood tools kind of twisting it and
turning it they're they're trying to
pull a real conversation and like the
real dialogue out of this [__] and that
was like super interesting to me hell
yeah yeah it's about time because we got
all kinds of [__] going on and then we
we can't discuss it I think it just gets
weirder though it's almost like a
relationship you know and like it's
getting weird in the relationship you
don't discuss it it just keeps going
forward there you go you can't talk
about it it's just gonna fester and it
also creates extreme energy the whole
size of things well that's the problem
with not having like all these news
networks it's all just for one group of
people and then you just get angrier and
angrier and that's that's social media
now yeah it is everything's happening in
a silo right did you see oh sorry you
see the Jon Stewart thing where he you
know he did the lab leak thing a year
ago or whatever with Colbert he showed
last week he showed the backlash he got
and he's like look look how bad this is
everybody says I'm anti-asian I'm racist
I'm uh I'm all right I didn't see that I
thought you were talking with a gun
interview oh that too well he said it
was made in a lab on Colbert and Colbert
was like well I don't know uh he was
nervous and then it came out that it
probably was from a lab and he's like
well look I was kind of right and
everybody trashed me but that's the
problem like I was just having that
conversation and like everybody has to
make a choice to tell the truth
and not this choice to not make people
upset yes on both sides people are
nervous just [__] be honest because
right now truly and from reputable news
sources not just like wild people
screaming things into like a tree sphere
right reputable news sources at this
point is saying yeah we're pretty
positive this came from a lab yes they
were pretty positive this is the
situation right which on some level
isn't that better yeah that that it was
an accident but it's like also
I don't know when that happens the the
the [__]
liberal media in liberals in general who
when Trump who I hate most of his
opinions right but when Trump was saying
this is probably some lab [__] right and
everyone's like you [__] dumb [__]
dummies you're so [__] dumb exactly
you have a responsibility to say hey we
were [__] wrong I know no one will
ever go back nothing wrong this one's
actually not that dumb because when you
don't validate and step up and own your
mistakes and own whatever the what the
truth is what you do yeah what you do is
then value validate the extreme right
who's like don't listen to nothing you
don't want tranquilizer nobody knows
what the [__] they're talking about yeah
you know what I'm saying you you sing it
sister yeah because you're not holding
to honesty and truth no matter good of
good or bad for you you have to hold
that Beacon especially if you're like
dudes yes or any type of source of
validation that we look to as a society
because all that misinformation from
both sides just creates distrust and
then you can't fault these people who
are middle of America sucking down horse
tranquilizers or not believing [__] yeah
because it keeps coming to be that this
[__] ain't true I think even the people
even saying it was horse medicine is
like kind of misleading of course but
but the uh you're right and
that's kind of where we're at now right
I mean it's I think they got so caught
up with hating the messenger right and
Trump that even if there was a message
that had truth to it they became
obsessed with just and you have to say
you know though we disagree with this
person there might be some truth to what
he's saying here and that's actually how
you keep your viewers long term hating
the messenger with a anybody yeah they
hate the messenger with anybody
everybody's caught up in hating the
messenger to the point where like
knowing some of the truth and that's
dangerous when it's news sources and the
[__] government like these are the
two things like like Society needs these
things to be honest yes it's the metric
so if you don't have that no one knows
what the [__] to believe I know but the
problem is also that they get their
ratings by saying outrageous [__] to
keep you on the channel when there's a
24-hour news cycle you keep people
watching by saying outrageous [__] and
that outrageous [__] is often like a
real a news channel that would be
reputable and actually trustworthy would
be kind of boring probably ah but but
now it's entertainment no that's the
course it is like when I was in um uh
Europe I did this joke and I'm sure mad
other people if you are a comic and
observer in Europe you did this joke but
I was like
yo I watched the BBC News and I was like
and this [__] was just news
but this [__] was just like this
happened up the street at three o'clock
right then this [__] happened like it
was just Al Jazeera was the same way
right right it didn't give you anything
else it was just like here is
information yeah there was no opinion
it's foreign
[Music]
a lot of times it it seems to be
factless at this point yeah yeah
that'd be great if they delivered the
news like you did some [__] happen over
here
I was like
like the anxiety
anxiety news because they were like
fires and uh Bronx people burning up it
was just like there was a fire in the
Bronx yeah
exactly and that's how that's how the
news should be delivered right monotone
somebody actually said that recently
like we should bring back Walter
Cronkite and they're like what do you
want to bring back racism of the 60s
like no no I want Walter crying just
give me news just give me news because
this news is crazy like and it's crazy
on every level it's not just politically
crazy last Halloween I was watching the
news and they were literally like
flammable Halloween costumes and then
they had a blow torch thing and they
were just setting costumes on fire wow
and it was like bro I don't even know
why I need to know this yeah yeah like
truly and honestly what are you trying
to do to me right now no just it just
make me [__] terrified well if you
see like what the the most popular on
the New York Times articles are it's
always something like Harry and Megan
and that's probably bad for them I also
you know because this is kind of
mindless [__] you know oh yeah and then
you look at the op-ed section the New
York Times I remember back in the day it
used to be like four people yeah now
it's like feels like most of the [__]
newspapers that's true good Halloween
costumes or something like that it was
like truly and they were like these
costumes burned and then you're just
Doom scrolling you just seeing school
shooting hate crimes
it's terrible I did two weeks in London
last year year on writing on a show and
it just feels so much lighter there
there's not that tension and everybody's
angry it just felt just a little more
laid back and it was weird but it was
great attention as much though in person
I feel like I feel like that's mostly on
Twitter right right and news and news
news is like pro wrestling now it's like
two sides ah you gotta pick us up and
there's no true to like it just feels
like the truth is just gone and like now
you can't I just feel like if you're a
liberal you can't keep calling these
people the middle of America [__]
stupid for believing what they believe
they call them [__] dumb and they
don't get it and they don't read enough
because the government and the media is
lying to everybody consistently and
constantly so no one actually knows what
to believe like they truly sat around
for a long time and so does aliens don't
exist and then one day kind of loosely
they were like they probably do and we
probably and we probably seen one and
then just moved on with their [__]
day yeah and it's like okay so people
are right to mistrust of course it's
like a toxic relationship with a
gaslighting you and then and then you're
just like well I guess you're the only
person I can be with yeah honestly
weirdly when it comes to certain things
like the alien [__] like the lab [__] I
believe Trump the most because I know
that he's dumb and he probably is
telling me [__] he's not supposed to
tell me oh boy good point because he's
stupid
no I'm saying so I think other
presidents knew how to keep all the
white Secrets yeah and he's just like
ignorant as [__] and he runs his mouth
too much right so he be saying [__] like
they probably told him a long time ago
yo we think there's some lab [__] but
don't say nothing and he was immediately
like it's lab [__] because that's how he
is yeah so if it's [__] like that I kind
of lean towards like this [__] probably
right the laundry is gone so long as
he's gone the funnier I find him
from China
also isn't it weird that we it's less
racist than it came from a bat in a wet
Market to me that's way like all these
dirty Chinese people making a [__]
soup with bats in it yeah yeah that's
way wild than just like a contained
thing yeah and a scientific space it's
weird that was the racist one right it
doesn't matter we were all like back
from Wuhan yeah that makes sense
because everybody's [__] garbage I
know
I think they've made sense that they
were like well they were disgusting up I
feel like like Instagram and Tick Tock
be feeling that stuff because they
always want to like I feel
like it's like this like
skewed American [__] that we want to see
Asian people do and it's always like
look at them eating a live squid and
pouring the sauce on it it's like it's
all racist sure they do more than this
yeah they invent a lot of [__] whatever
this is
yeah like look at them eating stuff we
would never eat and it's like I'm sure
there's also other things yeah there's
always like great Cinema and art over
there and we're just like we're like put
on one of the game shows yeah I want to
see them fall oh my gosh I'm saying it's
like we're not even tapping into like
the essence of their culture right right
we're just like Ninja Warriors watching
we're [__] for a while on Tick Tock I
got sent just videos of an Asian lady
slamming her face in the bread did you
guys see that one and I loved it
it was great yeah that's the problem I
mean we are getting Dumber oh yeah well
they say the tick tock's gonna go away
they've been saying that for a while
though I mean Trump was going to get rid
of tick tock remember that oh yeah
that's right they got rid of it in um
Canada you can't have it if you work for
the government you can have it oh wow
they feel like it's bad no it's run by
the JCP that the Communist Chinese
government and it's it's their property
it's a data collection exactly this
might sound ignorant but what isn't who
isn't taking data right now everybody is
everything everything you log on I mean
look look at this Facebook look what
Facebook has done well they don't want
them to China of course that's all it is
of course but I I mean it really is
amazing that like every time I mean
Apple caught [__] for like going on they
say ask app not to track Apple caught
[__] for that that's like pretty Pro
people I would think yeah yeah yeah you
know well that shit's crazy you ever
talk about like dildos then you get a
dildo okay what oh my God there's a new
squirting dildo I just learned that's
the word there it is that's the world
we're in that's crazy I'm fully in our
lives baby I know Facebook has a thing
called the off I think it's like the off
security track or whatever it's called
but you have to go to your Facebook
settings and turn it off so you
basically have to be like I don't want
you to spy on me it comes with them
spying on you Uber was tracking you five
minutes after you dropped got dropped
off yeah Uber was they're still
attracting you walking around walking
around why why was good questions they
said we were doing it to know where to
better drop you off next time so like if
we dropped you off here
but it's still like five minutes but
also that doesn't make any sense because
who says I'm going back there next time
[__] you don't know where I'm going
exactly yeah I go different places
right you go to mess Square Garden to
the next game what entrance should we
drive Mark goes to Mexican [__] shops
that was crazy that's [__] true
because now damn I didn't think about
that now whenever I type in Madison
Square Garden it automatically pops up
for pin because that's the entrance I
always thought oh [__] there it goes I
didn't even think about that it happened
to me the other day and I thought it was
weird I was like damn it went right to
four pin there you go you're a big Hoops
fan yeah you love basketball yeah who
how did you get into basketball who's
your first team was it that 90 Celtics
team no I was going to Celtics I was too
young like like the Celtics were too bad
to be fans of them you were like the
dino Roger yours I had one of my younger
basketball years it was squads because I
I my city sucks
but they were bad at hockey they were
bad at baseball they were bad at
football basketball so it was really
hard being a Boston sports fans but like
in the 90s and [__] so I would just pick
like squads like every basketball season
I had a new group that I liked how they
were playing yeah so it was one point it
was like the the Bibby Kings yeah they
were sick well they'd be all them then
there was the uh Alan Houston
um the next one yeah Sparks yeah Knicks
I like them for a little while you know
I mean I would just kind of then I was a
Kobe fan I was a huge Kobe fan so then
it was like the Lakers
for a while but even with the Lakers
because I wasn't from La like that I
would still be like I like Lakers and I
like right whatever whatever team or
whatever whatever team like that you
can't be a boss in person rooting for
L.A exactly so I had to kind of pick or
pick other [__] to also be into what a
great fluid way to be this is how Sports
fandom should be they should draft you
oh they should go for your like we spent
this much you should follow us this year
[__] your home sorry [__] your hometown
[__] your hometown but it's not a little
weather
who cares it's like build the best team
I'll follow you I mean I had to be at
the time like really like Boston had
nothing going on yeah like if I was I
didn't want to be miserable dog it was
like to be a Boston person at that time
it was like I wouldn't have wanted to
watch anything and it was some exciting
teams and exciting players oh yeah and I
started to just like what I like like I
love paiga you know I mean I started
picking players like I love how this
[__] play I love how this
[__] play I like how this
[__] place and that's how I
kind of like
um got way into basketball and then like
the Pierce you know kg that error then I
was like a Boston fan
and then I stayed like a Celtics fan but
the way I watched basketball if the
Celtics started like losing bad for the
next three years I would follow another
team now I'll be honest I never bought
another team's jerseys I never bought I
like I couldn't bring myself too much of
a Bostonian to like put on a Kobe joint
and just stand in that joint like if my
if my team sucked now Boston was also
competing fine I wear Kobe joint in a
brown joint and whatever we got
competitors but when we were like bad it
just felt like cheating yeah it felt
wild disloyal to do some [__] like that
right so I never did no [__] like that
you know what I'm saying I just didn't
buy nothing I was like I just don't wear
jerseys you know what I mean my first
jersey was a Celtics Jersey there you go
you know what I'm saying like my first
football jersey was a Tom Brady Jersey
you know I just didn't participate in
sports in that way until I felt proud of
my own City yeah the [__] that we were
doing that's why I didn't wear Fubu felt
like cheating yeah yeah I like that
about you mark you stay true to your
white man
some people man I like that about you
but I respect it thank you so some white
men got to go down with the [__]
everybody just can't jump off no I'm
staying on the other side oh my God you
[__] nuts
joking this is crazy they're gonna run
this [__] back in like 10 years and it's
gonna be like that clip they show Chris
Rock I know
that was a real that was a real heat
check from Louie yeah
let me drop the n-word in front of Chris
Rock his [__] face yeah I'm serious
about the FUBU though I didn't want to
wear it because it was literally for us
by us so I'm not wearing it no I'm
saying that's real like the white boys
who did it were annoying yes that you
just stayed loyal to your white [__] of
course to this day you're just a white
guy and I'm a white guy here here
nothing else
it'd be annoying if you did I agree no I
did and I like Mark Mark will say some
offensive white guy [__] and he don't
even know why yeah
like what are they mad about I'm like
you just you're just so white in the guy
that's a good equalizer saying [__] up
[__] you know because if I don't say it
around you I feel like that's weird yeah
you know for sure for sure
you can only be Mark they say Manny
being Manny it's Mark being marked
that's that's who he is
uh Ramirez what uh when are you gonna
tape another special June oh damn that
was quick what are you taping 0-17 what
yeah you just did one eight what six
months ago no the networks yeah three
years that's why I asked when you're
doing one well she had like 10 TV shows
in the movie I felt like that was right
she's doing other [__] like a year at
the most like 10 years ago all right
where are you gonna tape it uh Brooklyn
still oh I don't think I've been there I
think Jay did one there oh [__] is that
the one in like the warehouse he kind of
yeah but that's why I thought Jay did it
too but it wasn't it because it was
somewhere else but I thought I think I
have been there actually yes that's what
I thought it was too but he said no oh
okay
how he shot in there what it was like
but he said no but I think Ricky's last
one was oh gotcha the HBO one yeah I
like this place because you can kind of
make it what you want right right it's
very like and I wanted to I looked at
that one yeah it's like near the waters
I wanted to do New York I was like oh
it's time to do one where I live in what
was the last one Atlanta
okay
Atlanta's a good comedy City too yeah
but uh yeah that's exciting so you've
been touring with this one a lot
all right down there six seven months
wow yeah so you're trying to get 50 more
shows in before tape
oh I saw you the seller like a few weeks
ago and it was [__] hilarious it was
really fine yeah can I ask you about the
rock special you were there yeah what
was it like being there crazy yeah just
the energy was crazy she had someone do
it live and like that's a big deal you
know like yeah that's not easy to do
um
to just go for it live at five because
the truth is you can't predict the
energy you can't yeah you can't predict
energy you can't predict how the World's
Gonna Be and that's why we like to tape
too right that's what you do yeah I
taped seven last time for real yeah
that's what I'm saying typically you
lease that's not normal but you do at
least two at least two I feel like a
network unless they love you they'll
give you a budget for two right you know
what I'm saying if you're shooting for
HBO you're shooting four whatever unless
you like rock and you like I'm shooting
a weekly [__] show yeah and then we
gonna figure this out they'll let you do
too but like at the minimum you're doing
two and of those two you're picking the
best right yeah yeah what word how it
work because the energy is so
unpredictable yeah you know just you
just don't know what group of people
you're gonna be getting and laughter's
so infectious and the crowd did take so
much of how it works the the community
just show up with the jokes you gotta
show up with the jokes but if they're in
a mood and they make a decision and off
that first one they're like no and then
you perform worse whoa that could set
this whole world so to go like [__] it
I'm gonna grab my nuts and go live yes
take it as it comes well there's like a
weird pressure on the audience too to
bring it you know it's it's pretty
stressful but I feel like Baltimore you
get what you get they're not I don't
feel like Baltimore is like we're gonna
be nicer because it's a special yeah and
I mean that was intentional like Chris
purposely was like I want to do for that
reason yeah I come to Baltimore and like
grab my dick and see what it does so
just watch that energy and
did they broadcast that in the room no
wow he just walked out on stage wow yeah
with those boots
I didn't notice the boots that was a
wrist yeah it no he pulled it up but
yeah we all watched it and it was fun
yeah I watched him running a couple I
didn't see actually see especially but I
watched him run it a couple times and uh
and I yeah I love the material I thought
it was it was great yeah he just walked
out he's just for only one wow oh yeah
that night that's crazy I saw some video
I'm a huge rock guy like bring the paint
a bigger blacker to be a top ten oh my
God I think roll with the new got me
into stand-up I think I remember hearing
that album and just I probably got half
the jokes I was so young but I remember
I was listening that boy yeah
I I was uh I remember listening to my
mom was like what are you listening and
grabbed and I watched her put the
headset on and I watched this like look
of horror on her face uh followed by
like 30 seconds later her laughing I was
like oh that's [__] beautiful
like he can kind of push you away with
the premise and then bring you right
back that's Rock's gift yeah you know
yeah yeah he can say something really
polarizing and then just immediately you
nice it's it's a beautiful thing but uh
yeah I mean rock is one of the great oh
yeah ever I mean it's insane but what I
was gonna say is I saw a video and it
was this lady black lady saying that
he's he's not he doesn't play to Black
audiences like he's trying to perform
four white people and I'm like are you
kidding he's like doing it in Baltimore
I don't know it's such a crazy
accusation it is when did you see this
like a week ago so this is the crazy
thing I feel is like uh people's memory
is so [__] selective and it's gross
in my opinion because it's like
to say that is incredibly ignorant you
know what I'm saying was it bigger and
Blacker or better pain was that the
Apollo right you know what I mean it's
like you just don't know what the [__]
you're talking about totally CB4 is for
white awesome you just don't know what
the [__] you're talking about yeah No
Sex in the Champagne Room which for
white audiences like he was literally
being a black voice and the only black
voice in comedy like that for a minute
for us on that level yeah for a minute
you talking about the Chris Rock show
right for white people you sound nuts
and the problem I have especially when
black people do that is that they equate
success to whiteness so because he is
successful in this thing and he's not in
some dark corner right doing comedy only
in [__] Mississippi right and now all
of a sudden he's doing it for white
people and it's like shut the [__] up
you have no idea what you're talking
about it's totally disrespectful to the
man's Legacy his history the amount of
[__] he has done for black people the
amount of spaces that he has been in and
represented four black people in those
spaces just because you went to some
show and now that he's [__] a mega
star there happened to be a lot of white
people there yeah shut up [__] I agree
that's stupid true yeah white people
like him because he's funny I think I
think I think he's yeah he's and when I
see like someone like Megan Kelly post
how funny this special is and and then
people are like this is part of the
problem all you can do is put out the
jokes whoever's gonna like it is gonna
like it oh God there's been times where
I've done jokes in the [__] most
whitest whitest Republican man that's
coming to me and be like I [__] love
that [__] [__] about and I'm like I
guess bro I don't know I just said what
I said if it's good
I wasn't saying it to you bro
the job is to kill the job is to have a
good set so yeah I mean if you're making
people it's a good thing to bring people
together and also there's a lot of other
[__] too like it's like
he doesn't have to do all all the work
of Blackness yeah he's doing his corner
of his thing there's also [__]
writing books there's [__]
making movies this [__]
painting pictures so like if you're not
getting the thing from Chris there's
other [__] doing comedy like
just go search for it somewhere else he
doesn't have to hold up the whole job
that's so so well said I mean it's like
how unfair is it that that would be his
duty to I know he's an Entertainer I've
always said once people start putting
this weight on comic shoulders as being
more than just a comedian it's kind of
dangerous for comedy I agree once you
have this Duty as less important as a
citizen you know to be this even to be
like an artist people can kind of like
suck my dick because it's like yeah also
you're not doing any of this in your
day-to-day it's like yo yo you're
walking around the world you're
interacting with people all the time
yeah you're having these Encounters in
the world are you doing this [__] are
you doing this work that you're just
throwing on all these other people to to
do because what exactly because they're
on television I think often these people
are not you're right they're not going
out into the world and when we tour with
material we're at least seeing you're
honing a set based on
every state in the country liking it you
really are you really are you really are
making it work after you after your show
you're sitting at the bar if you
'd someone like we're not we're not
we're not like we don't we especially at
this level when we're when we're at this
level of Comedy you know not a Dave
level or Chris level it's like bro it's
not like I'm getting rushed off the
stage under a [__] jacket and no
one's allowed to talk to me I go to the
bar and if I make someone mad they walk
up to me and they're like you made me
[__] mad and I have a conversation
with them what were you actually [__]
mad about right I was mad about this and
I was mad about that well this is why I
said this and this is why I said that
and I take that and continue it into my
act and I go out and I keep building and
I'm having these conversations with
people in [__] Utah and I'm having
these conversations with people in
[__] LA and I'm having these
conversations with people in Wyoming and
I'm having these conversations with
people in [__] Atlanta so when I
finally stand in front of you with a
[__] special and I say hey I think
this might be the temperature [__] I
did a job exactly yeah I'm not just
[__] talking and also maybe you
happen to be just [__] talking you
haven't talked to anybody but you're
[__] friends so maybe you don't know
what the [__] you're talking about
you're right maybe you're in there go
chamber maybe you're in the Echo chamber
and I'm not I mean yeah the humility it
takes to hone an hour I mean you have to
you have to suffer a little bit I'm not
really suffer but bomb a little bit
sometimes you have to be wrong there's
been times I've done [__] and then
someone will come up to me after a show
with their real life experience and I'm
like God damn I gotta re-analyze what
the [__] I'm saying it has helped me
before not consider that I did not
consider that life experience I did not
consider that when I was talking about
this and now I do need to because now
I've heard it it's my responsibility to
now incorporate this or at least
consider this as I continue to say these
words and put this [__] out into the
world so it's like no you who just goes
to work and talks to your four friends
and comes home and that's all you're
doing and you're not actually out here
seeing and feeling and I'm not knocking
that but you don't get to come and tell
me what the [__] I should be saying yeah
yes that's not that's not how we're
doing it if they come at you in a
non-combative way I have listened and it
has been you know a positive experience
for me I remember
just get on the internet and
the intent is malicious is nobody wants
to hurt anybody right we're trying to
get all those people don't yeah but I
mean you know I remember a woman came up
to me after showing like 2014 and said I
had a joke where I say the word [__]
in it and she goes just so you know I
have a trans kid it's it's a slur it's
like a shitty word for us and I said I
didn't know that I'm glad you told me I
the joke Works she said to me the joke
Works without you saying that so I said
that's a good point all right it's gone
that's only all do that this is a nice
way to do it you know that's what I'm
saying that's real but that's what I'm
saying because you're going out and
you're doing [__] and you're being tried
and true and you're standing in front of
real people and doing this yeah so it's
like you're getting that real feedback I
feel like sometimes people see it
especially it's like you think that's
the first time I said it is [__] for
years I think some people might think
that I've been problem [__] for a year
I've been touring this [__] for a year
I've been tweaking it I've been tweaking
this for a year like yeah what do you
what do you I I didn't just write this
in the bathroom this morning all right I
think some people think that we do
though it's it's so frustrating but also
just because you perceived it a certain
way it doesn't mean that's how I meant
it just because it went in your head a
certain way doesn't mean I was going for
that I just wasn't [__] talking to
you just because you didn't get it
doesn't mean it doesn't deserve to exist
yes because you didn't like it doesn't
mean it shouldn't be around maybe I
wasn't [__] talking to you in the
first place maybe this isn't the
conversation for you there's a lot of
other [__] to go see there's a lot of
other [__] to go watch find the
conversation that is for you yes but
stop trying to eliminate conversations
from the [__] world because you don't
like them it's weird I agree it's so
[__] weird what if we do that with
everything hey this hot sauce burn my
tongue all hot sauce has to go that's
insane Behavior I don't know I'm not any
of this [__] like there's there's white
dude coming so I'm like I don't give a
[__] about whatever this guy's saying
but like there's some white guy
somewhere who does and he's listening
and he to his podcast he also deserves
to be like affirmed yeah
he's a person and like it just isn't for
me so I'll go do the things that are for
me and you should go do the things that
are for you and that's the great thing
about being in America and having
[__] options you know yes and having
freedoms and and it's interesting like
sometimes watching a comic struggle
through this is way more entertaining
than watching them kill like I've seen
you kill I've also seen those sets of
viewers where you're kind of working it
out and it's not quite clicking and
those as a comic are sometimes more
entertaining for me I like watching a
comic battle a good comic I don't like
watching a bad comic bomb I like
watching a good comic bomb sometimes
because they have to adapt right and
it's and it's interesting to me sure and
you're gonna bomb like you're out here
doing this [__] you're gonna bomb and
that's also another thing is like
sometimes I'll like like it's like maybe
it just caught me on a bad night baby
girl I'm a person yeah exactly I'm a
person out here just talking out of my
mouth I don't have a filter I don't have
an edit happening in between this it's
just me and you and thoughts so
sometimes things may get convoluted
misconstrued misunderstood because
that's how [__] conversations work
yes exactly and I think in this world
now everything's so curated you order
GrubHub gluten-free none of this none of
that but comedy they show up at a show
and there's like whoa I didn't sign up
for this [__] and I'm like well you kind
of did because this is a comedy show for
a live performance it
that means
yo what the [__] you're gonna get yes
exactly but isn't it great that comedy
elicits this type of response because I
think that means we're taken seriously
as a form of entertainment now we lost
his kid but don't you think that's like
think about how mad people would get
like Spike Lee or Tarantino and now I
think comedy gets that type of attention
I think it's kind of good yeah but I do
miss those old news days
and it's bad though because it's getting
that kind of attention but because it's
getting that kind of attention this is
the problem
Tarantino all this [__] is getting that
kind of attention from people that it
have been enough like familiarity with
like movies to get the medium I feel
like it's all these [__] just
coming to comedy that don't even get
the art form at all oh of course and
then they're just like
it should be this it is yes exactly
[__] do you even get what it is we do
but movies have been around longer than
stand up that's what I'm trying to say
like there's a consciousness of what it
is right that's just embedded in the
Americans right right I want Brian Regan
people don't get
the job that we do they don't get the
process that it is well there's people
that do but I don't think the average
just person who only watches specials is
never you know people have never been to
a live stream oh yeah I get a lot of
that but this only watch specials and go
like
I know what this should be yeah yeah but
the frustration also comes with like
we're turning over material that's the
frustration so you have to bomb and
that's frustrating and the comics who
are just going up and killing all the
time who these people might have no
problem with are Comics that they might
actually hate because that's a comic
that's not writing new jokes that's what
I'm saying that's what I'm trying to say
they don't understand exactly yeah like
this
this woman went under when I was
promoting the movie and she goes in my
comments and she's like I don't know
this bum got a movie I was just at the
cellar and this ass hat sat around and
did a whole set about Jeffrey Dahmer and
it was [__] and she was looking at her
phone the whole [__] time how the
[__] did she get it and I was like
you're not wrong lady that's what
happened that night
it was a Tuesday I was trying out a
dumber bit you're working out
I was in my [__] phone that was the
night but for her it's Tuesday and I
went out to I'm sorry yeah they don't
understand they had a big night out but
they're getting smarter like I I will
you know what I'm saying of course she's
just like who [__] me yeah I'm [__]
exactly but I think the crowd is the
audience has become much more
sophisticated I'm sure you deal with
this on the road too but like we talk
about this so much on the podcast like
new bits and all that [__] that I will
like take a notepad out on stage
sometimes and people like applaud like
they want to be a part of it now yeah I
think comedy crowds have gotten more hip
yeah no I definitely think that but I'm
but not every crowd obviously I think
like a lot the average comp that's a
comedy crowd right yeah right I think
the average person is like I come in you
off the top of your head bust my gut and
if you don't you don't deserve to death
that's a comedy seller that's a comedy
seller where you might be following
someone who is playing the hits so if
you don't come up and just murder right
that's why the seller can be hard to
work out at sometimes sure because
you're following some [__] murderer
yeah who's just doing 15 that's gonna
crush and then you're like let me see
what and they're just like what but they
don't understand that it's a choice they
think it's just you fat right right yes
they're like no you suck like no no this
will be great and you're like no baby I
could have hit you with the hits yeah
yeah I just didn't want to Darling
because this is where I work I work
right I work out it I gotta I gotta get
good yeah exactly that's how I get good
you know what I'm saying but they don't
and that and it's and it's weird because
then they watch stuff like Chris that
way and they watch you know what I'm
saying what's the first thing Chris says
when he pops into the seller lower your
expectations yeah they watch this stuff
with
text
S I did on this scale of like
well Eddie Murphy Raw yeah baby girl
it's Tuesday you thought you're gonna
get raw here you spend 15 bucks to get
here yeah exactly and and I know we've
said it a million what five
oh great yeah yeah now y'all I have
nothing to do
well it's been said a million times it's
called a comedy club but you wouldn't
just have a music Club because you could
have reggae country rap rock and you
don't know what you're getting but like
Comedy Club it's it's uh you then it's
uh you know Caitlin palufo then it's you
then it's Sherrod small it's all over
the place and so but that's what I'm
saying they also don't know like the
difference between you're coming to a
club on a Tuesday or you're going to a
samj show that's right several things
right if you come to a cmj show and for
an hour I'm in my phone doing weird [__]
about Dahmer and you pay 30 bucks yell
at me because I'm being bad
if you come to The Cellar on a Tuesday a
lot of I might not have even been on
yeah I might have just showed up and be
like yo can I try some Dumber [__] out
and they were like yeah you can this is
a different situation you hear all these
stories about like these roxies behind
the music videos these rock stars have
to be like carried on stage on heroin oh
yeah and then I'm like I had one bad set
where I was one of like seven Comics
right but every other art form they
understand that right like if they go
like back in the day when [__] you
had Punk at its height and they're like
we're about to go on a Tuesday to see
they knew they were just going to see
these [__] Jam yeah you know what I'm
saying they're like that's dope we gonna
go see these [__] Jam or you
know when you're just watching that's
why players shoot around and you're like
I'm not expecting them to give me game
right right every time we on stage they
want the game yes they want the game but
the but the thing about the game you are
bad at comedy but a musical a musical
but the musical bomb is is a harder uh
bomb to notice than a stand-up bomb like
if we're not connecting you [__] feel
it musician bomb you're like it's not
it's uncomfortable but it's not like
horror boy yeah yeah he's still playing
music
it's rare that you like watching a
musician and you're like I hate this
person
but that will happen to us strong
I don't like you
I know not as a comic but it's like a
human though like I don't like this
human
they think they know you and I'm like
these are jokes they're like I don't
like you right I'm like I just said the
worst thing to get a lab I don't believe
that thing people have been like you
need to be nicer to your girlfriend and
I'm like
hilarious what yeah like opposed to her
like David tell one time was like what
do you do with the guy goes I work in
Nickelodeon he goes no wonder I'm hard
and obviously he's not attracted to
children but it's the it's funny to say
that because that's the wrong thing to
be and that's comedy tells another one
who when he gets a bad crowd is the
funniest news
yeah it's just getting cranky and
oppositional they make you oppositional
and it's like you don't want to be but
when they're bad you're like all right
yeah [__] y'all exactly exactly now I'm
going harder I'm leaning in what was the
vibe at the after party for Rock was it
fun yeah but it's like
them [__] have been there and done it
right so they don't they don't have the
energy of new newness it's just like
we're gonna have a couple drinks and go
home that's kind of better at this point
yeah yeah I I just don't put our Chris
said there's no food I'm leaving you
know like that energy of like I gotta be
here doing this [__] like they're not
chasing no more and they're 56 or
whatever they're not chasing no more
right so the energy was that of of a
bunch of seat because Dave was there
it's like these [__] are
seasoned to know it yeah they ain't
chasing nothing I kind of like that
better because no it was it's cool to
see yeah I see the other side because
you know the after party is kind of
another performance and then everybody
goes that was great you killed it you
gotta go yeah thank you yeah it's more
work it's another job yeah it's another
job yeah yeah like I'm doing a special
in two weeks and they're like where's
the after party and I'm like don't do it
Chicago oh yeah the Vic Netflix
hell yeah are you doing Netflix again
that's exciting no no that's exciting do
you know we were doing it yet is this
live no oh totally Chris Rock okay oh
cut that it's going on Lifetime oxygen
[Laughter]
uh Tyler Perry bought a BT
or he's buying BT that's what I mean he
already owned it everything on BT is a
Tyler Perry show he's got like 20 shows
on that [__] channel oh geez I'm so
happy I got cable again for the first
time in forever and I'm so happy I got
it Cable's the [__] I never let it go I
wish I know why anyone would let it go
yeah I was just flipping around the
other day I was like yeah [__] it I
watched the last half of Cape Fear it's
[__] great to have that option I love
flipping it's my favorite part
essential it's like radio I have every
streamer but I've always kept cable
because sometimes I just like to
yeah
it's been a minute since I watched house
party right you're still making it
oh is it good
do we still have are we still picking
her up
put the captions in
I don't know do you see Pootie Tang I'm
joking no that's pretty tanks funny I
think Louie wrote that actually
controversial really I think it's pretty
funny it's funny
Robert Vaughn nah yeah
yeah it's funny we're doing like a lot
of long bus stretches uh for for we're
doing the tour bus like coming up like a
couple 11 day stretches and I just have
like booklets of DVDs I'm bringing and
you're like okay what's a good movie but
what's a good Bus movie you know I've
got like the dumb [__] I've got a road
trip on there I got don't be a menace on
there
okay oh geez what do I have white man
can't jump number one that's a black
moon oh yeah he's so white how is that
not black title is white man can't jump
there's an insult in the title
I do have a good mix in movies I even
have some foreign
I actually do a Friday in there Friday's
great I [__] love Friday oh yeah
Chris Texas Friday in the movie theater
really wow John Witherspoon in the black
movie theater yeah
damn money talks isn't a black movie but
I have that in there we'll take it we'll
take it I love Chris Tucker Chris Tucker
that we own it besides Fifth Element oh
yeah that's very white but he still
killed it he's always good dude Money
Talks is a [__] hilarious it's so
funny it's so good I wish that he and
Sheen did a couple more together because
they had like a good advice it was a
good vibe
that we don't got everything so
[__] heavy now man I know I
just bring back those because they won't
give they won't put out the very few
people just put out the light [__] like
everything like did you see the new
Pinocchio no no it's crazy sad sad
heavy I couldn't finish it because I was
like yeah
who is this for like yeah right it
starts first of all it starts they show
the real kid which is like we never want
to know who the real kid was that's
already too much so depedo kicking it
with the real son there is a bombing a
literal bombing the Sun dies in a
bombing Geppetto becomes an alcoholic
Jesus is that a kids movie you're like
yo wow it sounds kind of amazing though
the [__] is the art
the stop animation is dope but watching
it I was just like
why does it have to be all this bro I'm
convinced that's why Ted lasso became so
popular
the director also said like don't show
this to your kids well what the [__]
Pinocchio but it's like bro this is
great like he's a whole alcoholic like
getting drunk under a tree whoa like
ready to kill himself he's like he's
it's they insinuating like he's on the
brink of something right right like then
like Fairy come and the tree and they
like we're gonna make you a kid with the
kids all like scary looking like
Pinocchio's all gangly and like
it's just crazy you know what started
that up remember up great movie but in
the beginning I cried
Montage
it's heavy even house party like and I
think it's good but it's like the the
start of the premise of him like needing
money for his daughter and I'm just like
geez why can't we just be throwing a
party yeah
give me Goof Troop
I get it I heard Rush Hour 4's opening
with a rape that's what I'm saying
no it's uh it is I do I do love when a
movie can just be fun like I was telling
Mark I watched uh Megan that new movie I
heard it's good it's fun I watched this
[__] it's a fun movie it's lit it's a
fun ride Ronnie Chang was killed every
time he popped on screen he was killing
me and it and it's just like a fun movie
she's just killing people I guess it is
dark it's the beginning is dark but it's
like but it was like comedy yeah it
can't be a little bit you know like it's
like come on dog I was into it and then
once you start dancing and [__] you're
like this is just goofy
yeah you're right though it is harder
like
it was kind of good good that's a hell
of a story once it got to the point
where like the maid got pushed down the
stairs by dogs they killed the Baby Bro
of course I don't know what dogs do but
you know it's Shady he also lied to the
family like I'm gonna hook y'all up with
the bread
no I was like at least give him the
bread you know you killed the maid well
OJ commented on the the jury that was
fun he's become a legal course
he killed his wife and his kid he did
but I know that
he killed enough people that he needed
to go yeah oh yeah yes exactly you
didn't do this you was a part of so much
foul [__] right that something something
was gonna catch up to you bro you just
was laying too many foul bricks also the
one of the uh one of the sons was
clearly either I mean gay or yeah I mean
they killed this gay kid Buster yeah
that was [__] dark as hell Buster
they and they still ain't even talked
about what they did to the gay kid they
kind of glossed over him like this
family's coming to so many murders they
can't even get to the wow hate crime the
hate crime was the lightest part they
were like yeah
that's how they do it's gay so they're
like yeah and it was a gay kid murder
but
what
was the other uh so him oh and the woman
on the boat obviously yes that was the
major one yeah that was the start of the
neferty yeah yes they are some Southern
trash right there oh yeah I was like
this is this is turnt it was kind of fun
it's good let's go insights into like
this like like white [__] that you like
cause like because the black person you
like they they be doing crazy [__] and
then every once in a while you get a
little window oh yeah oh I know it white
collar crime is crazy I don't know why
but like the rich ones are easier for me
to take like making a murderer where
they're just [__] with like poor
people it kind of it really depends yeah
yeah yeah
Rich piece of [__] they'll go down I
mean they did Kill A lot of people but
no the maid was the [__] though that was
a [__] yeah that was the main was just a
casualty of of addiction and needing
bread right you know I mean like it was
just like we need bread
I get high too much who can we take out
they were so powerful that they told the
cops that dogs pushed a woman down a
flight of stairs and the cops are like
that's good enough for me they're so
powerful they went to a crime scene and
took out the major piece of evidence
yeah right move the boat they took the
boat out it was like true what and then
and then the boyfriend was like can I
see my girlfriend they're like we're not
comfortable with that yeah no baby and
then even people in the interviews are
like we're kind of nervous talking about
this yeah that's how scary they are yeah
still how did they time it to come out
with the the jury well that was Ill that
was amazing I mean that's probably how
you do it that's incredible Wonder
though is that gonna be something he
uses to try to turn over his conviction
or like uh cereal
no in a sense of magic spoon it's like
jury tampering a little bit right
because it's like can you guarantee that
they didn't hear nothing about this
documentary right guarantee that they
didn't hear anything about this like if
if I was a defense attorney I'd be like
hey I hate this guy can guarantee that
the jury didn't get any of this
salaciousness well that is amazing
you're right I mean it came out at a
time where it could have influenced the
jury and this is a bunch of opinions
in
in Japan
running right in line with this [__]
yeah and I don't know that I don't think
the jury was sequestered I didn't see
that yeah I don't know yeah so I didn't
hear anything about a sequestering so
then how do you you know yeah it's
really it came at the perfect time
because I feel like there hadn't been a
good murder crime uh True Crime Doc in a
while I I'd been pretty they made so
many and they were just bad what I love
about it too is the root of it is just a
bunch of trash Southern boys that like
to get drunk yeah like it's not it's not
even like high level [__] it's just like
trash [__] who drink too much
crash a boat yeah push a [__]
downstairs
it's not funny
when you say push a [__] it's kind of
funny yeah I mean it's like the crimes
themselves are just like trash yeah poor
white trash crimes with from people with
money like yeah
it's a weird combo yeah he's just struck
out our oxy making rash decisions and
the other kids in some Ivy League school
plagiarizing you're like you're just
you're just shitty people oh this [__]
yeah yeah it was uh but there hadn't
been a good one in a while I tried to
watch the Hulu sex cult one and it was
like
yeah anytime I watch it like that I just
get annoyed with white people it's just
like y'all y'all just be participating
just stop cult they don't need to be
real
real she got in my head
you told me I had to and so then I did
it and it's like [__] just go home
I know I never got that that's cold just
say no yeah go to your house you're a
little annoyed they fell for it I'm
annoyed that they be acting trapped and
things that are like right that are just
it's not even crazy like even when I
watch the Scientology one the dude was
like then he pushed me and it's like
sock that [__] I know what are you
doing
they kept acting like this guy was like
this high level con and then I hear
everything he'd say and I'd be like
that's not that yeah it's a guy named
Greg or something you know in a bathrobe
oh I'll tell you something the lady one
oh no there's a new one there's a new
one too many sex clips where it was like
a woman and she her whole thing was like
uh powered orgasm and making
[__] nut in the power of
nothing and stuff but then when you got
into it she was like on some crazy [__]
and would watch people getting like uh
like self masturbation and other people
touching other people's clits and be
like you got [__] this person because
you're you're clouded right now and then
the people just go [__] someone they
didn't want to [__] yeah because she
said they were clouded and now they're
all abused and it's like everyone could
have went to their house
I know I don't get it everyone could
live anyway she wasn't locking the doors
on nobody nobody was stuck there yeah
they were all in San Francisco up the
street it just shows that people need a
group go yeah people need somewhere to
go and that I mean look at covet
everybody went nuts because no one had
anywhere to go or dude I wonder why
would [__] like this happens it doesn't
get introspective ever people never go
what was wrong with me I know they just
go what was wrong with me then that I
was looking for that that I needed that
that allowed that into my life and my
spirit that I allowed myself what was
happening with me because that's the
first question I asked for all my [__]
yep all my [__] good or bad I'm like
what was what was going on with you yeah
yeah you let this go this way people
don't do that they just go like she
crazy and but also something was wrong
with you that you let a lady tell you
how to [__] a stranger and you did it
exactly how about internalizing a little
what's up with you at that point in your
life and have you fixed that yes you
have it you gonna meet another person
I'm not saying I'm just saying if I was
a cult leader I don't want to be an
occult it's too much work Mark you are
not a good dude your first wife whatever
that was a janitor
wow that's funny as [__] because it's
true
yeah it's so weird to me because I'm
like all that [__] is just someone
playing on your on your weaknesses yes
acknowledge is recognizing and just
pulling those things out and twisting
them around yep and it's like you got to
fix that [__] you have to fix that [__]
I know because it would make you
vulnerable all the time and if you never
go
then you know I'm not saying don't get
these people but
there's a bigger conversation right
right
as the biggest conversation why am I
[__] be so
yeah ready to go to this type of [__]
right yeah there's agreeable and then
there's maybe you should fix that yeah
yeah can't no one tell me I gotta [__]
another person
to clear myself of whatever the [__] and
I'm just like doing it and I don't want
to yeah you know what I mean and they
get to wear a robe before this all
happens it doesn't seem fair no then I
go back and report to them after I [__]
the person and I'm like I [__] them am
I better and they're like yes but what
the [__] game is this are there cold I
know how to be a hoe by myself
if you need a hoe just got a hoe just
say you in a holy face all right
we don't need a whole leader why do you
need a group to hold you can hoe on your
own you go I want your own but I think a
lot of people are followers they need a
group and that's the [__] it's like it's
important like
that was a big thing my mother droved
into me was not to be a follower yeah
that's like and when I was following
like it was like I got in trouble for
that type of [__] so not having my own
mind like why did you do that and if I
was like because such and so that was
more punishment that was if I was like
because I there's a different
conversation but if I was literally like
because my friend that was like you were
in trouble trouble right because now
you're not thinking for your [__]
self you're a follower [__]
think for you so now we have a real
problem yes yeah so now we have we have
a real conversation to be had and I
don't think people get that it's like
that's important well people when I give
your independent brain yeah but people
are scared they want that acceptance so
bad that's what hashtags are it's like
oh we're doing this now all right I'm
all in on this like well I've never
heard you bring that up once in your
life well now I'm all in oh I hate that
[__] I know it's crazy I hate that [__]
because it's like also you can't care
about all these things how much do you
care for real when you hashtagging 30
things right I think oh I think about
like Cecil the lion no one gave a [__]
about lion exactly a day before that
happened can't care about this [__] bro
it's too much [__] to care about and you
can't really care if you just like
hashtag lying
diabetes
stop Asian hate and then you find that
that person's like a deadbeat dad on top
of it right and then they feel better
they go hey look at me I'm hashtagging
all day long I'm a hero like yeah you've
been on the beanbag chair you ain't been
doing [__] yeah you didn't do anything
well like are Asians good now does that
just end like I don't get how that works
I'm like yeah in a sense of art isn't
good it's like is now do they not have
their issue exactly like the [__]
they're going through in the world the
Discrimination they're going through in
the world
the negativity they're going through is
it now over because you hashtag exactly
I hate that [__] I hated the black
Square [__] it's also kind of [__] up
to do it for just like a month because
yeah it's almost like you're just
forgetting about it yeah
and it gives you a false sense of uh I
feel like I got I feel like I got forced
into one of them it was like one of them
it was like
y'all [__] is making me do this cause
it's black and if we don't do this oh
and I hated how I felt I can't remember
what it was but I hated how I felt and I
like took it down pretty quickly because
I was like this feels good for you gross
and you get resentful you're like [__] I
gotta do this now you're mad at the
group gross like what do what what is
this yeah what is this [__] weird ass
nobody cares but everyone's pretending
to care but everyone's a piece of [__]
thing that we're trying to [__] sell
right now I know and who are you selling
it to exactly who are these overlords
we're trying to please you selling it
too because everybody's bad right we're
all twisting everybody's [__] up up
the chain and down the chain ain't
nobody living fully right you got that
right I'm trying to start a cult
Marshawn I started cold
I got a robe in a basement
well Sam so you're taping it on April
17th no June 17th June 17th at Brooklyn
steel any of the road dates you want to
plug no website man I'm outside catch me
outside
I love that girl I'm outside boy you
know I'm outside all right you can see
her at the cellar a lot yeah yeah the
seller
uh yeah we're all over I'll be around
like white boys when I'm when I'm doing
white boy stuff and I'll be around
a lot of black people
I love that you can just catch me doing
stuff you know there you go San Diego La
that's where you're going that's where
you're going You're plugging your own
dates on your own stuff am I not allowed
to do that [__] gay
I'm a big homo
um
more days at San bruno.com I'm coming
all over same get a bottle of Bodega cat
per day okay glasses what's my daily cat
that's our whiskey we sell you got a
whiskey together oh yeah your whiskey
pedaling and
another screen
why have I never heard about this one
it'll be at the cellar soon we'll be
drinking it together ever have this look
in your bottle I hate y'all
well there you go you heard it here
first folks uh yeah thank you so much
for coming Sam you're welcome I'm gonna
get yelled at for this wow
why are they going to yell at you for
this I'm talking to two white men and
I'm not yelling at y'all
well you can get one in before you go
yeah hey y'all stop being bad and stop
being white yeah and do what you need to
do to uplift the black community in the
gay community
oh yeah all right so you and yeah you're
part of the problem too
yeah hey I donated delivery and I don't
agree with nothing y'all said because
y'all white there you go so you're wrong
and I just want that on the record you
heard it here thank you for coming Sam
all right got some black points
[Music]
Defender
I've even wrecking all the beer Juice
close
[Music]
and
I get down in the same way
up on the room
[Music]
is feeling dangerous
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
[Music]
we might foreign